nor am i
walking how i imagined
that samurai would walk
just bend your knees
so
he's got some resistance and if i just
try to walk he'll
catch my center of gravity as i'm going
forward so i have to establish
single footed points
so each each step is a culture
projection
not walking into free space or
then i have to charge satan with
violence
my eyes don't wander i'm not looking
around
and prioritize him
he's the threat so i'm moving in
and i want that connection with his
weapon
so i'm not just touching it and it's
dead
it should get stuck on him
this year's life
so i'm thinking about too
i'm waiting to see what he does okay
so there's a time when i go to say god
and he
he will match it so we're not giving
away
any opening okay i'll take the center
line
and he matches it
then my stance is under me because i
don't know where i need to go so don't
get in a
bracing stance
okay so working with the same charge
notion the yo
you okay everything is charged
so right now uh we're too close
so i have to pay attention to the mod i
still have the same measuring
drill okay so in other words like oh
i can hit his hand so i have to be in
that right
sweet spot of range okay same thing
i have to make sure that i'm in a mine
that is conducive towards the wood
weapon
and not any kind of grappling situation
and he goes into his hands or something
you get it so i have to be in that sweet
spot
now if i'm out here then i'm not a
threat to him
that's why it's a sweet spot i can't be
too close and i can't be too far
so i'm out i'm in this perfect spot
where he wants to fight with the weapon
he does not want to fight
with his uh body yard but i can hit him
or he can hit me within a ski range
alright so now comes the problem
how do i move there
most people take the line of gravity
between their feet like that
so you can look at it you're going out
and then
down out and then down
and instead i have to establish that
ground vector
i have to drop down and then
out so it's the exact opposite i go down
and then i go out so first let's look
you're going to be
stressed on the end of my web okay i'm
gonna try
to do the other one and again you have
the same problem that you'll have in
saigon
you won't be able to go forward you have
to establish the ground vector
down and then you can go forward with
the coq projection
so if i get caught in the middle
boom i'm actually not going to do what i
think i'm going to do
but there's a range variation that
happens too
when you go i'll move the little side
when i go out and then down i can't
really penetrate that far
because i don't get that thrust into the
movement
so instead i'm going down
home and then you can see my weapon can
do its job
[Music]
so we add that movement to the drill
okay so he's going to give
go from this neutral to give the opening
he's going to adopt that position and
the opening happens
there so that is where i start my
movement
just like saigon i'm matching him whoa
i have to match that would i match it
with the dropping down and establishing
of the rear
vector
then he's going to work on his ukemi so
i don't want him running away from it
and i don't want him nailing me i will
pull it as i need to
but i'm going gonna do my job he does
his job
i'm reading his body
okay let's go he's doing that drill and
i'm going to bring another training
aspect into it
uh so i'm gonna give the opening go to
and uh i'm going to ride this one
so i'm not gonna go like this
i want to i want to increase
my measuring capacity
he's not he's doing his thing you do
your thing
that would be a mismanagement
but so is this i want to get used to
staying
in the crucible
i want to hang out there
you can go go
okay let's go okay so
that last drill is about an acceptance
of the violence so
if he's coming this is not accepting it
he's still trying to be safe okay
he goes i'm just riding this thing
so somewhere you are he goes and you're
here why didn't you go this extra far
just be right here is there
is i'm going to use that skill which is
more of an emotional acceptance of
what's happening
uh to be in and do ushito tencon
i want to lure him in
not moving make him not want to do it
i lure him
then we go slow for the details
up
up turn your palms
not straight turn your palms this is
basically
show man wrist turn
single pivot point then you're out of
the way
then the timing can't be he goes
wait then i go
so it's not realistic
um or let's just say it's delusional
that i afford myself a superior
speed and give him an inferior speed
so if i'm doing two steps to their one
step
this is not sound reasoning okay
so when i if i go here
and i go one and you go
two i i will be a b behind so let's say
he's going to double ski he won't
stay in the same rhythm okay
we'll go we'll do the other one okay
we'll just stay slow so you can
slow slow okay one
okay um
let's also look at another one
a worse one i'm going to do
three so you can see what it is he does
his ski
and i'm going to go one two
three do you see again so you can see
one i'm sorry
one two three
then kill double ski on that one
got the idea okay so what we're doing
with the shiro tencon
is uh he's coming in and the game goes
slow
so when i i'm luring him into the
initial ski
and i'm shifting off the line
all i gotta do now is rotate and he's
missed
do you see
so we'll do it on the other side
okay so when i establish the rear
vector i'm moving to the right
he goes and then i rotate on that rear
vector
he's missed this step is not for
deviation
this step is for acquiring the new line
of attack
the deviation already happened
on here one
two
do you see then
on the go watch what i'm doing
i already put the right hand in place
i don't leave it here then i'm going to
try to move it boom
it'll tend to get twisted up let's do
that first
on here and right here you're twisted up
half body on the other one your initial
stance in essence
so bring the weapon to
with you to you home
it's all ready to go there's your
showman turn your wrist
and you have your kesa
um
so don't get hung up on this block it's
not a block
the deviation already made him miss okay
so instead prep your weapon boom deviate
boom
we don't block so i don't need this
movement there
i'm not hitting his hands i'm going for
his head
so okay the deviations
okay try it okay another beginner
mistake
is he's coming in and you were told i'm
not hitting his hands
and i'm i'm baiting him in so i don't
want to i don't want to deflect his
weapon
and so your solution is that you
take your weapon here you see
and this is not this is not very strong
so i want that angle i want the angle
instead
okay so i'm here like this
and he pushes my leash see i can't get
it but if i come underneath
there's more integrity to the weapon
second point on that
is i'm already performing the kesa
so we'll just get there okay so
the kesa is hidden here okay
and that that's my angle
and so this is the plane that i want to
work on
so when i come around to here
this this is what goes around boom
i don't want to have one angle here then
i come down and i get a new angle it's
just
a single plane that goes around
boom and hits there okay so
so here
i don't have to push his weapon to do
that
i might have to get lower and come
underneath his weapon more
but i want to keep that angle boom
right into kesa
so the beginner mistake is you're not
tailoring it to his height style
preference and you're like oh that would
be wrong
so let me just go here that's also wrong
instead move the juji underneath him
more
you'll feel his pressure so i go to make
contact i feel that
that's where i stay so i don't push past
it
but i don't go into it i stay right on
what he's given me
bait
keeping one plane into kessa
okay okay so directional harmony and
body fusion i need
i need that when i do this okay so he's
coming in
okay got my weight shift that's that's
this is what my body's doing
won't pop that's what my body is doing
my hands have to be uh working within
that
so i'm going one i'm going to go real
slow from the top
okay don't start away please go go
okay i'm here boom you see where my
my hands are in front of me okay
so they're going to turn with me as i go
and i'm not going to leave him here
because now i'm twisted
oh my hands come back with me the joe
comes back with me
this is very common but very wrong
on your hair like this you're all
twisted up
the weapon and your hands come back with
you boom
i'm never going to be twisted then we're
going to be like this
when this foot is back here this is back
here
right here
wrong okay let's go